[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to a very different episode of Fandango
indie movie guide right now I am in
Portland Oregon rainy Portland Oregon I
have just rented a car and I'm driving
up to Mount Hood in Oregon for the
Overlook Film Festival which is all
about horror films and I'm on the jury
so I thought I would take you along for
the journey let's do this probably
should have gotten snow chains there to
get up the mountain didn't think I was
going to make it at a few points
white-knuckling the whole time but I did
I made it and I'm here at the Timberline
hotel for the Overlook Film Festival not
the Overlook Hotel but it was used as
the exterior for the Overlook and The
Shining and I'm not in room 237 but I'm
in room 211 and it is a very very cute
little hotel
as I said I'm on the jury here and there
are a couple of Australian films which
are part of the competition and I wanted
to tell you about two of them
particularly hounds of love this comes
out on May 12th and it is brilliant it's
set in the mid 80s it's about a girl who
gets kidnapped by these serial killers
who are a husband and wife and she
quickly realizes that they have a lot of
issues she's trying to figure out how to
get out of the situation by maybe
playing on their emotions it's very
smart it's more of a psychological
thriller but deeply disturbing at the
same time so I highly recommend hounds
of love the other ugly film that's
playing competition is called boys in
the trees it's directed by Nicolas verso
this is set in the 90s and it's all
about the to date work in you end up
confronting their own demons and their
ghosts from the past during Halloween
night it's beautifully shot it's like a
little mystery it slowly reveals itself
and the type of movie that you keep
thinking about long after it's done
the hallways are not quite as creepy as
the Overlook Hotel but hotel hallways
always a little bit creepy I also got to
see MFA and stillborn which are two
films with great female leads MFA is
about an art student and MFA student who
gets raped in college and then she
decides to take revenge as stars
francesca eastwood directed by an
italian light and i thought this one was
really well done i think mainly because
francesca brought something emotional to
it stillborn is another one with a
female lead and this is directed by
brandon christensen and it's about a
woman who has twins but one of them is
stillborn and then she starts getting
attacked by a demon in her house or she
could just be suffering from post partum
depression it's creepy and lots of jump
scares again the theme of tagging Esther
who played by Christie Burke did a
really good job at grounding the story
[Music]
so it's pretty creepy at night but I'm
making my way back from sea you can even
see weak from that scene killing ground
man Australians know how to make some
creepy stuff I really liked the
structure of it it was exact this young
couple who were camping and the same
time was telling a story about this
young family who are camping the family
ended up being hunted down welcome so
through the past but you're putting
together the story at the same time even
though that was set apart from each
other
haha but sincere paths were really
freaky even get much of a sense about
why they did what they did but it was
pretty creepy and I really liked that
the girl had a lot to do
in the end the altitude can be
[Music]
this is the very first overlook Film
Festival and it's been created by two
guys who a programmers at other
festivals including the Sundance in the
midnight section so they spend the year
traveling around the world to festivals
watching all these horrors and thrillers
and then for this festival they've
hand-picked some of the best that
they've seen from around the world so
today I also saw a film in the UK called
two pigeons and this is very creepy it
is directed by Dominic bridges and it's
about this real estate agent who lives
in a tiny apartment but he doesn't
realize that there's another guy who's
living there secretly and then this guy
starts to ruin his life
so I love a self-contained movie as you
guys know and the fact that it is all
set in a small apartment really adds to
that claustrophobia and then makes me
very paranoid and makes me want to check
my bed underneath it to make sure
there's no one sleeping in it for I
guess sitting and ricotta cake is great
there is a little bit of a glass of wine
is almost an device
last night Miss Mara morning and then I
have scared I'm having such a great time
also have to be another movie the first
one is called like me from the US market
by Robert no class as anything that is
always balanced this young girl is once
the internet famous cheese learner very
much by itself very reckless as well and
he holds up a convenience store and it
really popular on the Internet so she
gets more and more brazen he met the guy
but ends up having amazing relationships
right native so it's a fascinating movie
so it's not really well survival
sacrifices without felt different and
when I saw the previews movie of are
told the world
Toxie crazy from Thailand
a bunch of little people living in
Thailand their tribe
they can't eating these berries that
they found and then only in skewness
zombies I guess some beings that like an
area of a person that that was lastly if
I put it crazy movie but it's kind of
fun to see something that really goes
out there and not seeing anything else
like this at any other festival preside
over a film festival and fantastic
special one Holly always loved film
festival there are people of the
observation tower that was pretty cool
that was too short radio plays voiced by
actives
I love seeing stuff like that live
acting where you have to use your
imagination to picture what's going on
very very cool experience and next up is
a secret screening which are here is
from the folks at a 24 which makes me
think I definitely have to go
[Music]
the secret screaming was a movie that
coming out later this year from a 24
called it comes at night during a great
cast election common is Jojo
Christopher Albert Riley Keough and it's
certainly first autistic world where the
most of the world has died from a
mysterious illness and so these two
families are trying to survive and
there's a lot of fear there's a lot of
distrust and nobody wants to get sick
that's pretty brutal it's extremely
intense and there were plenty of times
when I was away and plenty of times when
I held my breath it's directed by Trey
and which Schultz to near Krisha which
is a great tiny Lindy from a couple of
years ago that he shares with his family
so if you enjoyed that film you haven't
checked it out but if you enjoy that
film that this DM doing Cora and he
really shows so much promise as a
director
[Music]
at the end for my time here at the
Overlook Film Festival it has been so
much possible including this festival on
my radar to come back next year
me and the jury decided that the grand
jury prize to go through hounds of love
Australian films and we gave a special
mention to the scariest film which was
stillborn because that movie later jump
so much hopefully get to see all these
films and thank you for coming along
with me on the journey I'm going to head
back down the mountain
[Music]